[Music]
August 2004 the quick bird to satellite
passes 280 miles above Patagonia central
Argentina
it captures a geometric pattern etched
into the arid terrain this is quite a
striking image
it's very vivid very bold you've got
these very straight very regular lines
forming a kind of matrix structure the
image comes from the remote desert
plains of Patagonia's rio negro province
details in the image leads some to look
into the unlikely idea that this could
be some kind of desert leisure complex
the dots do pose an interesting thought
because of the spacing and the dimension
of the dots it could look like a
irrigation line for a fairway sight one
of our Gen Tina's top golf destinations
is just 90 miles from where the image
was taken perhaps the satellite has
spied another golf course under
construction in the desert on a desert
golf course you'd probably have about 20
to 30 miles of irrigation pipe under the
ground you need high-tech pumping
systems to make sure the exact amount of
water is delivered the deserts of
California Nevada and Dubai have all
been transformed into lush golf courses
by sophisticated water management
systems possible this could be a big
irrigation system being installed we'd
see the network for the pipes and song
but if these nodes are greens there are
simply too many here for a traditional
18-hole course the lines are quite
randomly placed without a continuous
flow it doesn't look like a golf course
to me
zooming in reveals structures that could
offer clues to the nature of the bizarre
markings to me looking at this image I
think is pretty clear that we're looking
at some kind of extractive technology we
can see there's some kind of equipment
down in there a lot of the dots have
some mechanical structure by them
probably an oil derrick one interesting
feature of the Patagonian area is that
it has been a target of the last decade
or so for oil exploration the final clue
to the mysterious shape records indicate
that a state controlled energy company
recently discovered oil reserves in this
region in excess of 40 million barrels